APRIL SECOND ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
NOTICING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
I WILL GO AHEAD AND START AS A
SUB COMMITTEE -- I SEE A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
[inaudible]
HE HE HAS ONE BILL.
HOLD ON PLEASE.
AB SEVENTEEN ENJOYS IT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND CAN TAKE A VOTE ON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT [inaudible]
REMEMBER[inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T LIKE TO BE
RECORDED CAN WE TRY THAT AGAIN
ABSOLUTELY PERFECTLY.
PRESENTED IF THANK YOU LETTER TO
ACTUALLY IF YOU HOLE I'M SORRY.
ONE MINUTE I THINK WE CAN
ESTABLISH FORM NOW.
YES AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER PRESENT
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
CALDERON.
CHECK OUT.
DATE EGGMAN FONG GABRIEL.
FRIEDMAN.
MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
WORK HERE READ THIS.
WITH THAT THIS DOES ENJOY PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU BETTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT FOR YOU
SIMPLY BILL SEVENTEEN IT'S A
VOTER PROTECTION MEASURE WE'VE
HAD A LONG DISCUSSIONS I
APPRECIATE.
THE CHIRPING A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE SEEM
DURING.
THE LAST ELECTION CYCLE WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF SOME
ISSUE SINCE THE PROBLEMS --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I'VE
MOVED DOWN THANK YOU.
THE THE MOTION RIGHT AFTER QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
AND FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW ME
ASSURE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DO NOT HAVE A FILE ON THE
BILL AT THE TIME AT THIS TIME.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS. TWENTY
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND THAT BILL IS ON
CALL AND WE'LL TAKE IT UP --
SINCE WE ENOUGH MEMBERS HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR HOLDEN.
MR HOLDING YOU BE PRESENTING ON
AB SIX SIX NINE IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- SO
PLEASURE TO BE BEFORE YOU TODAY
TO PRESENT SB.
SIX SIX NINE A BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO USE A TYPE OF SELMA -- TO
CALLED ASSURANCE VOLUNTARY
CONCESSIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU ARE THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HI THIS IS ANTHONY LEE FAN
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S HOW WE HAVE
TO SAY ARE ENOUGH IS THAT WITH A
SPONSOR FOR THE BILL IN THE DRY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE APARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY.
MS CREEL AS SECOND BY A MISTER
QUIRK -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
THE BILL CREATES GREATER
EFFICIENCY FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR PEROT NOT
VOTING THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN
[inaudible]
HEY.
SINCE I SEE NO OTHER AUTHORS
HERE WILL HAVE DOCTOR QUIRK
PRESENT HIS BILLS.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AN OUNCE AB
SEVENTEEN BY MR SALAS GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL.
WITH THREE PETS EIGHT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
MISTER BRO VOTING NO AND MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING HI -- YES MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB.
FOUR FIVE ONE WAS
INTRODUCED HELP INDIVIDUALS WITH.
JUST SO EVERYBODY'S CLEAR MISTER
QUIRK IS PRESENT ON BEHALF OF MR
SANTIAGO AB.
FOUR FIVE ONE IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- EIGHTY
FOUR FIVE ONE WAS INTRODUCED
HELP -- INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS.
CRIED WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS
CRISIS OBTAIN TIMELY ACCESS TO
ADDITIONAL SERVICES IN CARE.
REQUIRE PSYCHIATRIC UNITS WITHIN
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS.
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITIES IN
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY MAINTAIN AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY CARE TO RELIEVE OR
ELIMINATE PSYCHIATRIC.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CONDITIONS
VISIBILITY IS AVOID ACCEPTING
PATIENTS IT LIMITS ACCESS TO
CARE.
AND REDUCES CAPACITY.
THE SPELL THESE BEDS SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL PATIENTS FACING
EMERGENCY MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ALREADY REQUIRED TO ENFORCE
FEDERAL AND STATE REGULATION OF
HOSPITALS.
THERE REALLY SHOULD BE NO
ADDITIONAL COST TO MAKING SURE
THESE FACILITIES ARE ACCEPTING
PATIENTS.
ANYONE DEALING WITH THE METAL
HIGH HEALTH CRISIS YOU HAVE
TIMELY ACCESS TO NEEDED
PSYCHIATRIC CARE.
UP WITH ME TODAY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS TO
MADDEN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS TO SPONSOR
THE BELL.
AND I WILL ADD THE BILL WAS
INTRODUCED BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA --
AND WE SANTIAGO AND I ARE
HELPING HIM OUT YEAH.
JULIE GETS -- TILL THE
PROCEDURES ARE ALL FINISHED.
THANK YOU AND THAT HAS A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO AND A SECOND BY
MYSTERY OF US.
I'M SURE MEMBERS TO MEN
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AS MR QUIRK NOTED
WHERE THE SPONSOR THIS BILL WILL
HELP US CONNECT OUR PATIENTS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING A MENTAL CRISIS
TO THE CARE THEY NEEDED A HIGHER
LEVEL KERR TO PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITY.
AS THE ANALYSIS NOTED THIS AS
MINORS OR WILL COST WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I. BUT
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
ANY PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS -- WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE.
HAS FURY VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK
ON BEHALF OF MR SANTIAGO --
JUDGE WORK YOU HAVE A BILL UP AS
WELL AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN REQUIRES T..
TOLD AT LEAST FOR PUBLIC MEETING
TOOK THE BILL SECOND.
WITH THE MOTION BY MISCREANT A
SECOND BY MISTER REVISED. FOR
PUBLIC MEETINGS EACH YEAR TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON PERMITTING
CLEANING UP SITES ENFORCEMENT
REGULAR ACTIVITY I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
DINNER BROUGHT ON BEHALF THEIR
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CNN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
DOCTOR QUIRK THANK YOU.
I. AS C. NO.
MEMBERS.
MISTER CLEAN MISTER RODRIGUEZ
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE MEANTIME
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU CAN
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
ASSUME YOU'RE WAVING OF THE
HEARING ON THE SUSPENSE ITEM AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN AND ARE PRESENTING
ONLY ON A BEFORE SIXTY NINE
CORRECT IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
EIGHTY FOUR SIX NINE WHICH IS
SPONSORED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND CHURCH STATE RECORDS
WILL BE MANAGED PROPERLY AND
CONSISTENTLY.
SO THAT THE PUBLIC AND
RESEARCHERS CAN ACCESS THEM IN
THE S. WESTERN STATE ARCHIVES
THIS BILL MOVED DOWN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND DAD DO YOU HAVE A
WITNESS OFTEN THE SPONSOR HE'D
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS THANK
YOU THAT WAS A MOTION BY --
DOCTOR QUIRK A SECOND BY MISTER
BRO AND ANY WORDS IN SUPPORT
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THAT TRAVEL
OUT THERE ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY
OF STATE ALEX MEDIA I JUST HERE
IN SUPPORT.
OF OUR SPONSOR THE BILL WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
FOR REFERENCE ON IT.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON NOTE THAT IN YOUR SEATS SHORT
TIME HERE IN THE COMMUNITY LEARN
EXACTLY HOW TO PRESENT A BILL
THANK YOU MISS BETWEEN OUR HAS
THAT I GET OUT.
A ROLL CALL.
MISS CREEL IS GOING TO PRESENT
FOR MISTER KALRA.
SHE WILL PERCENT AB.
FIVE TWENTY IT IS ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
GOVERNOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON A SECOND BY MISTER
REAVIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED.
MISCREANT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS A BILL.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA -- WHICH WILL TO FIND WHEN
A PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS DEFINED AS
THE MINIMUMS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DETERMINING AND THE PREVAILING
WAGES APPLIES TO PRIVATE
PROJECTS AND USING PUBLIC FUNDS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
OF YOUR MEMBERS AS EARLY AS ME
HALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS ARE CAUSED BY THE
TERMINATION REQUEST MADE ON
PUBLIC WORKS WE ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION --
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MIKE WESTWOOD DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN SUPPORT.
DIDN'T THINK YOU'D BE IN
OPPOSITION SORRY ABOUT THAT
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER SILVIO FOR HIM
TO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT A COUPLE THINGS --
FIRST WELL THE BILL I THINK THAT
THE FACT SHEET THE DISCUSSION ON
THE BILL HAS TALKED A LOT ABOUT
COMMERCIAL HOSPITALS.
THE IMPACT ON RESIDENTIAL IS
REAL AND IT'S BIG.
IF FOR INSTANCE MANY OF OUR
PROJECTS TEAM UP AND PARTNER
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH THE
STATE ON A NUMBER OF VARIOUS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE
ARE LOOKING -- TO FURTHER REDUCE
ENERGY -- ENERGY EFFICIENCY
CLIMATE CHANGE PROGRAM SOLAR
PROGRAMS BATTERY STORAGE
PROGRAMS.
IF THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF
THOSE INCENTIVES IN OF THE
PROJECT NOW TRIGGER TO INNER
CITY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT PROJECT ACROSS THE BOARD IS
PREVAILING WAGE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A MINIMUM OF EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DOOR AS
APPLIES TO RESIDENTIAL OR RENTAL.
SO I KNOW WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
IMPACTING OTHER TYPES OF OF
CONSTRUCTION BUT THE IMPACT ON
RESIDENTIAL REAL.
I THINK THERE ARE TWO OPTIONS --
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
RESIDENTIAL -- HAVEN'T HEARD THE
AUTHOR TALK ABOUT RESIDENTIAL I
THINK WE CAN CARVE IT OUT OR WE
CAN JUST GO FOR TO CODIFY THE 2%
WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT IT HAS BEEN USE ROUTINELY
BEAT BY THE D. I. R..
THEY HAVE COME FORWARD AND SO
THEY DON'T USE THERE'S A PROBLEM --
AND WE HAVE NOT HEARD EVEN IN
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO THIS BILL
TWICE BEFORE HIS SAID THERE DOES
NOT APPEAR TO BE A PROBLEM.
SO WE WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
IN A FINANCE.
NO FILE DOCTOR PARK DOES HAVE A
QUESTION.
YES IT'S MORE OF A COMMENT.
THERE ARE TWO PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN FULLY PERMITTED RESIDENTIAL
HIGH DENSITY PRODUCTS PROJECTS
NEAR TRANSIT IN MY DISTRICT --
AND THEY'RE NOT BEING BUILT IN
THERE NOT BEING BUILT BECAUSE
COSTS ARE TOO HIGH -- I HAVE
PROJECTS IN EACH OF MY CITIES
THAT ARE NOT BEING BUILT BECAUSE
THE COSTS ARE TOO HIGH -- RIGHT
NOW PEOPLE ARE BEING SQUEEZED I
HAVEN'T LOOKED AT THIS BILL IN
DETAIL BUT THAT THE THE EXTENT
IT WOULD.
STOP RESIDENTIAL PROJECTS WHICH
FRANKLY FOOT RAISED COSTS IS
COSTS I THINK IT WOULD I WOULD
NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL I'LL
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK
[inaudible]
MR ROVE.
MADAM CHAIR -- I AGREE WITH THE
CONCEPT WE WANT TO PAY WORKERS
MORE MONEY.
PERHAPS IN THE FUTURE WE CAN
LOOK AT WHAT IT ACTUALLY COST TO
BUILD A HOME WE HAVE LUMBAR
TAXES IN CAP AND TRADE INCREASES
STUCCO AND CONSTRUCTION COSTS
AND SOLAR ON THE ROOF AND OPEN
SPACE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IMPACT FEES ARE
HUGE -- SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
BILL WHERE MAYBE WE ELIMINATE
SOME OF THE BUREAUCRATIC MONIES
TO COST.
IN THE CHURCH AND AND PAY
WORKERS MORE WHO WERE WORKING
ESPECIALLY IN MY AREA THEY CAN'T
WORK AND LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
AND AND A HOME THE BILL.
I WOULD RATHER GIVE THE WORKER
MONEY AND ELIMINATE A LOT OF
THIS GOVERNMENT -- PERMIT FEES
AND OPEN SPACE AND SEEK WAS ALL
THAT STUFF SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER IN THE FUTURE ON
ELIMINATING SOME OF THE
BUREAUCRATIC -- BARRIERS AND
THEN WE CAN PAY WORKERS MORE
MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER ROWE.
YEAH WE'LL BRING YOU THAT BILL
WILL WORK ON IT TOGETHER PAY
WORKERS MORE.
I LIKE THAT.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE SEQUEL
STUFF BUT ALL RIGHT WITH THAT I
SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS --
MYSTERY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMENTS I THINK WE
ARE ALL IN AGREEMENT ON THAT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
NEEDS OF OUR SPECIFIC DISTRICTS.
WITH YOUR PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO
HAVE ONE OF OUR THE WITNESSES
AND IN SUPPORT RESPOND TO SOME
OF THOSE COMMENTS.
WOULD WOULD YOU LIKE THERE'S NO
NEED TO KNOW YOU CAN IF YOU'D
LIKE OF A VERY BRIEF -- MANAGER
MEMBERS I I THINK WHAT WITH THIS
MISTAKE IN YOUR BY THE
OPPOSITION SAYS TONIGHT IS THAT
THIS DOESN'T CHANGE THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF WHAT TRIGGERS
THE PREVAILING WAGE WHAT TYPE OF
WORK.
THIS IS JUST A PUBLIC SUBSIDY
THAT IS RECEIVED WHEN A PRIVATE
DEVELOPER CHOOSES TO ACCEPT THAT
PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED BY LAW TO
ACCEPT PUBLIC SUBSIDIES AND THEY
WANT TO BUILD HOUSING WITHOUT
USING PUBLIC DOLLARS DOCTOR
QUIRK I THINK THEY CAN ARE FREE
TO DO THAT AS WELL.
I'M NOT SEEING THEM.
ALRIGHT WE WILL AND MOVE THIS
DISCUSSION AS THIS BILL MOVES AS
WELL BECAUSE THAT GETS OUT ON A.
B. ROLL CALL WITH MR IDEA
PUTTING I THINK.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR GLORIA.
AB EIGHT NINE THREE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I
BRING BEFORE YOU AB EIGHT NINE
THREE A DISTRICT BILL WHICH
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF FIREARMS
AND AMMUNITION AT THE STATE.
FAIRGROUNDS IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT -- THIS BILLS IN
RESPONSE SHOULD OVERWHELMING
CALL BY MY CONSTITUENTS THE
SENATE DISTRICT AS WELL AS THE
CITIES OF DEL MAR SALATA BIJAN
ENCINITAS WHO SUCCESSFULLY
PETITIONED OUR LOCAL FAIR BOARD
TO END GUN SHOWS ON THIS PIECE
STATE OWNED PROPERTY.
YOU'RE NOW SAYS CORRECTLY POINTS
OUT THE MINE ACOSTA DEPARTMENT
FOOD AGRICULTURE TO UPDATE THE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THIS BILL THIS
COMMITTEE HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
APPROVING.
OF PROHIBITIONS OF GUN
AMMUNITION CELLS IN OTHER
AGRICULTURE DISTRICTS ASKED TO
SIT COURTESY BE EXTENDED A
TARGET SHOULD AS WELL AND ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO
IN A SECOND BY MISTER REED
DOESN'T BUT WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CAPPING LYNCH
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY
SPARK CLUB INTERNATIONAL DOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION.
ALL IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
THE AUTHOR HIGHLIGHTS AT CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY THEY
DON'T WANT THE SHOW BUT THIS IS
A STATE PROPERTY OWNED BY THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
NOT AN EXCLUSIVE GROUP OF PEOPLE
SHOULD BE NOTED ON A REVENUE
IMPACT AN ACCESS VERSUS SINCE
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN AN AVERAGE
OF FIVE SHOWS PER YEAR.
WITH AN AVERAGE OF SEVEN TO
TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE ATTENDING
PER SHOW INCLUDING THE MILITARY
A LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE AND
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL WILL DECREASE STATE LOCAL
REVENUE AND A BILL PASSED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS REQUIRED ALL
FERRELL'S.
FARE SALES TAX REVENUE BE SHARED.
WITH THE NETWORK AFFAIRS THUS
THIS IS NOT A DISTRICT BILL BUT
IMPACTS FINANCIALLY ALL FAIRS IN
THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS BAD FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IS CREATES A PATCHWORK OF
ACCESS FOR A LEGAL AND REGULATED
ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA.
BY CREATING A BIFURCATED SYSTEM
FOR THE DISTRICT AGRICULTURE
ASSOCIATION FACILITIES.
THIS IS A A WE HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S A
MODEL FOR THE NATION.
IT BEARS REPEATING THAT ALL LOS
CURRENTLY REQUIRED FOR FIREARMS
AMMUNITION SUPPLY AT THE SHOWS
AND REQUIRE PROCESSING THROUGH A
DEALER.
AND NOT HAVING THIS -- THEN YOU
CAN CREATE AN UNDERGROUND MARKET
LASTLY THIS MATTER IS UNDER
LITIGATION AND THE FEDERAL
COURTS UNDER FIRST AMENDMENT
GUARANTEE FOR FREE EXPRESSION.
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE THE
FAIR FACILITY IS STUDYING THIS
HASN'T OFFICIALLY BANNED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE TWENTY FOR
THE RECORD AND RE WITH NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE FOR
GUN OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA ECHO --
MISS LYNCH IS -- COMMENTS IN
WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NAY IT OUT SO WE HAD TO PEOPLE
JUST MAKE SURE IT'S YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. FOR GROWTH ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE THINKING.
THANK YOU.
I SEE MORE OPPOSITION SEPARATIST --
REPRESENT A GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY MORE
OPPOSITION SCENE AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
A BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
I JUST LIKE TO NOTE -- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR -- ALTHOUGH I'M A BIG FAN
OF RE DISTRIBUTING AT AT OUR
SUCCESSFUL -- FAIR REVENUE WE WE
HAVE ONE OF THE ONLY SAN DIEGO
COUNTY ONLY FAIRS THAT OPERATES
IN FACT -- FOR A PROFIT WE DO
SHARE WITH OUR ROLE IN --
COMMUNITIES IN STATE WIDE IN
ORDER THAT THEY CAN KEEP THEIR
FAIRGROUNDS OPENED BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN I I BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD BURDEN -- OUR RESIDENTS
WITH EIGHTY ATTENTION THAT THEY
ABSOLUTELY HAVE BEEN CLEAR THAT
THEY DON'T WANT SOUTH THANK YOU
FOR DOING THIS BILL AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE COULD SAY
ABOUT ANY MANAGER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SMART MAN GETS OUT ON B. ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
MISTER BROWN WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO MR PEROT YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING AB FIVE FIVE ONE IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB FIVE
FIVE ON SIMPLY UPDATES CURRENT
LAW TO REQUIRE DRUG TESTING --
IN FATAL ACCIDENTS TO INCLUDE --
NEW THINGS LIKE OPIOIDS FAT AND
ALL AND MARIJUANA RESPECT RUSSIA.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CREE ON A SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE [inaudible]
THANK.
SEEN NO COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST RESPECT THAT FOR
OTHER PACKAGE OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE MISSING AUTHORS
NOW WE ARE DOWN TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT ON THE COMMITTEE SO WE
ARE LOOKING FOR MISTER RODRIGUEZ
MR COOLEY.
THOSE ARE FOLKS WHO ACTUALLY
HAVE BILLS THAT HAVE TO BE
PRESENTED ON TO BE MOVED OUT IN
THE MEANTIME IF WE CAN -- LIST
THE BILLS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR INTAKE
EMOTIONAL CONSENT COUNTER
MANAGER.
MAKING THE CHAIR SECRETARY.
AB 586-525-5380.
ONE FOR TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX
BY 465-886-09611 SIX NINETEEN
FOR SEVENTY THREE NINE OH THREE
AND TO KNOW THAT.
THAT IS A CONSECUTIVE.
THANK YOU AT MOTION BY MISS
EGGMAN.
SELECT A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THAT
GETS OUT ON ANY ROLL CALL.
WE WILL NOW READ THE BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY [inaudible]
AB. 292-035-5250 513-315-4190
SEVEN TWO OR 321-423-6260
1-263-277-2782 843-003-11312
322-331-3363 435-438-8390
639-742-6420 843-847-4764
895-055-1718 BY.
FIFTY BY FIFTY SIX BY
575-816-2966. 266-236-68670
768-268-8730 381-883-7920 SIX
ELEVEN ELEVEN TWELVE D. THREE
AND FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE SO NOW
ALL OF THOSE BILLS HAVE BEEN
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE IN
THE AUTHORS -- HAVE DEEMED TO
THEM BUT NOT NECESSARY TO
PRESENT ONS OF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN THE AUDIENCE WHO CAME TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO ANY OF THOSE BILLS AT THIS
TIME THEY CAN COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION IN THEIR POSITION
ON A BILL THERE'S NOT ANY TO DO
THAT BUT IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
CAME AND WHERE.
I'M EXPECTING A PRESENTATION NOW
IS YOUR TIME.
SEE NOBODY MILLION -- WE WILL.
GIVE THESE AUTHORS MISTER COOLEY
AND MISTER RODRIGUEZ OF ABOUT
THREE MINUTES MORE AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE OUT OUR
MEETINGS SO.
WE WILL WAIT
IT'S GREAT I I
UNDERSTAND BOTH MEMBERS ARE
STOCKING COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW BUT
DOCTOR QUIRK IS WILLING TO
PRESENT ON THESE BILLS.
BOTH OF WHICH ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- MR TRACY
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT ON A
SUSPENSE FILE HOWEVER YOU DO NOT
GET HERE IN A TIMELY MATTER AND
THAT HAS BEEN ALREADY MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILES SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE -- PRESENTATIONS
[inaudible]
IF.
DOCTOR QUIRK WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT THEN THESE ARE A MISTER
RODRIGUEZ HIS BILL IS AB TWO
NINETY FOUR IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE MOTION BY MISS CARILLO
IN A SECOND FIVE MYSTERY OF US.
THIS BILL REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
UP WARDEN OR COUNTY SHERIFF FOR
ADMINISTRATOR.
POST A LEGIBLE NOTICE IN EASY
EASILY AVAILABLE LOCATION TO
OFFICERS EMPLOYEES.
OF THE PRISONERS OR JAIL TO
DESCRIBE THE RIGHTS OF VICTIMS
OF GASOLINE AND PROVIDE PHYSICAL
NOTICES THEIR RIGHTS TO EACH
VICTIM OF GASOLINE.
IF YOU WANT I CAN DEFINE THAT
BUT I'D RATHER NOT NO THAT'S
THAT.
I THINK YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB --
WOULD YOUR SUPPORTERS LIKE TO
JUST SAY THEY'RE IN SUPPORT --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GATHER
MCCUE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU.
GREAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NEARLY PUT JOHN WITH
MAKE YOU HAPPY AND ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION BENEFIT TRUST FUND
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY -- AUDIENCE
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DIFFERENT FINANCE.
NO FILE THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE START QUIRK AS FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
I'M SURE MISTER RODRIGUEZ IS
THANKFUL THAT YOU PRESENTED HIS
BILL -- MR COOLEY ALSO HAS A
BILL AB SIX TWENTY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN ON THAT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
A MOTION BY MISS EGGMAN A SECOND
BY MISTER OBERNOLTE.
YES THIS BILL DEFIED SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
THE BILL REQUIRES A CORONER TO
NOTIFY THE PARENTS RESPONSIBLE
ADULT.
OF A CHILD -- THAT MEETS THE
DEFINITION OF IMPORTANCE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF TAKING TISSUE
SAMPLE FROM THE DECEASED CHILD.
THE IDEA HERE IS THAT IN THE
LONG RUN -- THERE MAY BE A
GENETIC PROBLEM -- THAT YOU CAN
IDENTIFY AT THE TIME BUT IF YOU
SAY THE TISSUE AND SCIENCE
ADVANCES YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO THE
THE PARENT OR GUARDIAN WHY THE
CHILD DIED.
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT NOW.
THANK YOU -- DID A GREAT JOB OF
INTRODUCING IT GARY COOPER
REPRESENTING THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND HAPPENS TO BE A
NEIGHBOR OF MINE WHOSE SON DID
PASS AWAY AS TO DC AND WE'RE
VERY THANKFUL MISSED COOLEY FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING I'M CHEN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH THERE ON BEHALF
TO CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CORNERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
[inaudible]
NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE AS FOR YOUR VOTE THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR
BIGELOW IN MISTER FONG NOT
VOTING.
WITH THAT THAT IS THE COMPLETION
OF OUR AGENDA TODAY I WILL SIT
HERE FOR FIVE MORE MINUTES IN
CASE ANY OF THE MEMBERS NEED TO
ADD ON ACTUALLY MAIENSCHEIN.
MISS.
MISS FRIEDMAN FAT INTO DATE.
FOR MR GARCIA AND SHE'S HERE TO
ADD ON WITH THAT ALL ALL MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN HERE SO [inaudible]
WE'RE DONE